after penning um another terrific
football morning in america column that
can be seen
uh on all of nbc sports platforms
including pro football talk is peter
king how are you pk
rich eisen how are you i'm doing better
for talking to you that was so much fun
yesterday i i just it was fantastic it
was a great day and you know
the reason why
we're all sort of addicted to these 16
18 weeks whatever it is
however however long you watch
the reason we're all addicted is that
every week
something really really interesting
happens and so i'm sitting there
yesterday i've got to try to figure out
what is the most interesting thing most
weeks in the nfl to write about and so
i looked at the the green bay
new orleans game you know i looked at
every game but i looked at the green bay
new orleans game and i just thought to
myself
you know it's amazing and ridiculous
that the packers lost 38 to 3 and that's
a that's a fascinating topic to go into
but
i mean
you know it wasn't long ago that we left
jameis winston for dead laying on the
side of the road
and
and look what jameis winston
has done
right now and again no one knows if this
is an outlier
no one knows you just have to let it
play out
but he couldn't have had a better first
day
uh in his new partnership with sean
payton and
and i thought really the most
interesting thing that i learned about
the nfl this weekend
is when i asked jameis winston
what is the play about this game that
you'll remember what's your favorite
play of this game
and he told me
my favorite play was a ball that i threw
away
late in the first quarter i love it and
because it says so much about where he
was
and where he is now
that
that it's a good play sometimes to throw
it in the first row of the bleachers
you know and and
it when you hear that you think to
yourself well that must be drummed into
his head quite a bit by
you know every coach that's in his ear
from sean payton on
on on on down um
and it's also got to be just a
maturation process that comes with
watching last year and going through
whatever he went through in tampa and
and you know him speaking we played the
sound bite earlier in the first hour
peter of him talking about how this is
for the city of new orleans and you know
taking on the mantle of leadership it's
just
great to see just terrific
to see and and look in the other thing
he told me yesterday is that
uh first of all you know he was in
middle school when the breeze payton
marriage began and
in new orleans and he grew up in alabama
so they got the saints games on sunday
and he started to watch it and he said
that's when i started to say man what a
dream it'd be to be in that offense it's
so quarterback friendly
and so yesterday before the game there
was something he really wanted to say
to sean payton
that he's been thinking about ever since
he signed with the saints a year and a
half ago
that you know this is like a dream for
me to be the quarterback of this team
and so
that plus the fact that when you're
around a guy like drew brees who focuses
on process and not on the scoreboard i
mean look everybody in life has to be
scoreboard oriented i get it
but brees always used to say both to
winston to taysom hill
uh you know to all the guys who have
been quarterbacks in his room over the
years
forget the score forget the scoreboard
just make every play as perfect as you
can focus on the process of being a
great player
and so that's really what has happened
now with jameis winston
that
you know every play he wants to win
every play
and if you throw an interception or a
pick six i mean his last play in tampa
bay bucks history was a pick six against
the atlanta falcons
uh in the final game of 2019
that bruce arians uh after the game and
thought about it he said well you know
if we don't have any other alternatives
we'll bring them back
but we're not going to bring a guy back
who is so careless with the ball and so
last year just sitting there watching
was great for jameis winston peter king
here on the rich eisen show and peter it
really is amazing how things play out in
the nfl it's a week to weekly guys i
know but we're just obviously looking at
the snapshot of week one if i had told
you late may early june deep
in the abyss of rogers is never playing
another snap for the packers again
deep in that abyss that not only would
rogers play for the packers in week one
but
the
result would be so dreadful that jordan
love would get in the game and actually
get his first snaps as a green bay
packer quarterback because of the
complete
lack of everything that rogers and the
packers were able to do
i mean what a mind-blowing
week one result for green bay what's
your take away from that well
i think
right now week two becomes
really really important for this team
and i think they'll play well there's no
reason to suggest
that this is going to be a continuum
at all and i just don't believe it will
be
i believe the packers will come back
play very well we'll be fine and rogers
will be great again this year
the only thing
that bothered me about that game
yesterday
from the green bay standpoint
is that
i never saw one piece of evidence in
three hours and 15 minutes
of
any packers being really pissed off
and being and basically grabbing the
game by the throat and say we're not
going down this way
they just they just took it
and
you know look aaron rodgers is not one
of these
i'm
demonstrable
demonstrable um
yeah demonstrative
uh
leaders you know he's more of a leader
by example
and a quiet leader with guys in the
huddle he'll talk to him but he doesn't
read people out and all that stuff
i mean to me
i really think that i mean i noticed
that a lot yesterday and i said
somebody had better
you know spend some time this week
saying that this is never gonna happen
again
um it can't just be left unspoken
and so that is the only thing about
yesterday that really worries me almost
how flippant the packers were about
getting their rear ends kicked like an
aaron rodgers team has never
uh gotten beat in 14 years as a starting
quarterback in the nfl peter king here
on the rich eisen show the week one
result for the browns what do you think
about that
because they got you know they got
mahomes
a lot of teams have gotten mahomes but
that's the second time where they could
have actually out my homes mahomes
um
this time rich is that
this time it wasn't
they didn't have the benefit of a chad
henny half of football
to basically stay in the game
and to have a chance to win late
this time they were going toe to toe and
they were even beating mahomes
uh obviously and rich i think they would
have won this game
or there's a very good chance they would
have won this game
without one of the most incomprehensible
plays
any of us have seen and that is
a punter dropping a ball
that is right in his hands
and seeming anyway seeming uh to just do
a total absolute choke job
that handed the kansas city chiefs the
winning points of the game
handed the chiefs what an 11 yard field
to score a touchdown to win the game
and again
you can definitely blame baker mayfield
for trying to do too much
on the the interception he threw to mike
hughes uh you know on the last drive
you can blame him and and maybe you
should blame him but he was in the
process of throwing when daniel sorensen
came up behind him and was tackling him
and so it's hard for me to blame
mayfield on that play
but clearly you know the browns
should grow from that and the browns are
a really good team
i i considered i i still
you know don't know if
if they're a super bowl team and that
game yesterday was a discouraging game i
would think for those who think that
you know the browns
are ready to to bash the door down peter
king here on the rich eisen show after
the first sunday of 2021 and tonight on
monday night football's radio coverage
that i'll be hosting on westwood one
between the vegas raiders and the
baltimore ravens peter king will be
joining me uh on halftime
of that broadcast right here on the rich
eisen show at the moment though
i i was at the um opener last night here
at sofi peter
how'd you like it unbelievable
unbelievable and and i was mentioning
that um
i was mentioning that it may be the
first time the los angeles rams la rams
have ever had a home field advantage
quite like that it was loud yeah
it was like a rock concert i got home an
hour later it was still ringing in my
ears and it's just the general sense of
whatever the team must have felt
when you know stafford showed up and did
what he did last night 20 of 26
um 321 yards three touchdowns um jb long
who calls the games local here uh
tweeted out that with td passes of 67
and 56 yards in his rams debut that's
the first time stafford has multiple
touchdown passes of 55 or more yards in
a game for the first time in his career
he gets the game ball it's a beautiful
new stadium for the team fans are going
crazy i i would be uh i would i'd be on
the lookout if i'm the rest of the nfl
not just strolling in that building
which is what tom brady's gonna do uh in
a couple of weeks um but just the way
the team must be feeling right now i'm
wondering what you could tell me
anything from your insider position of
what you've heard or what you've talked
about leading up to this or after last
night about this well rich i i spent
some time in training camp uh with sean
mcvay uh you know and
much less time with
stafford and aaron donald but here's
what i thought
coming out of that team coming out of
that camp okay
that sean mcvay
has an encyclopedia
in his brain of plays he wants to run
and i believe that
um if there were 26 volumes
in the world book encyclopedia when we
were kids
and they would be on our shelves and we
would look take out the l
and and look at uh you know whatever
we wanted to look up for research in the
ls
that in my opinion
i think that
when jared goff was the quarterback of
the rams
that
sean mcvay did not feel comfortable
using every volume in his encyclopedia
and i think now he looks at matthew
stafford
as really kind of a complete player
not that goff was not going to get to
that point but goff was more of a
student and
stafford is more of a peer
and i think
that that is why i mean i
honestly rich that's really the reason
why i picked the ramps to win the super
bowl
i think that i think that uh
that that is
you know and look they don't have the
margin for injury
like teams like tampa bay do okay
but
i do believe that
they're going to have a really great
chance
as long as they can open up
every week
and call
you know almost any play that mcvay
desires and the one thing that really
stuck out to me rich
is look 8.5 yards
is usually right around the best yards
per attempt
in the nfl every year maybe up to nine
yards okay
but yesterday in his debut stafford's
yards per attempt was 12.5
and what that says is he's not only
being accurate and and and and you know
making
making almost every pass count but he's
also hitting plays downfield and that is
what sean mcvay desperately has wanted
in his offense an efficient
quick strike downfield thrower and now
he's got one so you know we'll see how
far they go peter king here in the rich
eyes and show a couple more minutes left
all right peter i'll just open it up to
you and what you found out last night
your what was your favorite quote
that you got
from sunday's coverage give me that one
which one did you like talking to
somebody or you heard or you read
anything like you know probably
i would say probably the one
that
uh
you know when when i'm asking jameis
winston about
his favorite play and he says it's this
it's the ball he's going to throw out of
bounds and he said to me he goes listen
i was going to throw that ball
so far over his head that even shaq
couldn't intercept it
so that that to me it just says that you
know hey throw it away and
and live and live for another day
the one other one rich about yesterday
that i thought was really cool i was
talking to tyrod taylor after the game
and hey look hats off to tyrod taylor
what a guy what a performance
i i mean everything that that guy has
been through
i i just really i've got great
admiration for him
but i asked tyrod taylor about the
national anthem because i don't know
about you rich but i
i was blown away
by that girl
who was six years old when her dad was
on the 102nd floor of the world trade
center
and he was just working
a a regular day in the united states of
america
and he like twenty seven hundred others
in those buildings
never came home
and
she is now twenty six has the voice of
an angel
and had it together
to be able to sing the national anthem
right by her dad's
uh inscribed uh
you know name
at the memorial uh at 9 11 in lower
manhattan and tyrod taylor told me he
said man that was really really
emotional to see that he said the whole
stadium was emotional those are the two
things from yesterday that i remember
peter i'll talk to you later i look
forward to it thanks again for this
peter sounds great rich all the best man
that's peter king at peter underscore
king on twitter must follow as his
football morning in america column
always a must read
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here